مع توالي المصاعب الميدانيه وتعثر خطط
الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا تحاول القياده
الروسيه استدراك الموقف عبر تعيين قائد
جديد لقواتها في اوكرانيا اذا عينت هذه
المره الرئيسه هيئه الاركان المشتركه
العامه الجنرالفيري جلاسيموف قائدا لما
يسمى بمجموعه القوات المشتركه بديلا عن
سيرجي سوري كين الذي تولى المنصب في
اكتوبر من العام الماضي والذي نظم انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من مدينه خيرسون في مطلع
تشرين الثاني نوفمبر في معتبر نكستا كبيره
للكرملين
في عام
1955 خدم في جميع انحاء الاتحاد السوفيتي
ثم تراس اركان الجيش 58 اثناء الحرب في
الشيشان حيث ذاع عصيته لكنه ظهر الى
الواجهه اكثر خلال عمليه احتلال وضم شبه
جزيره القرم عام 2014 وتشكيل الجيب
الانفصالي في اقليم جمباز في عام 2013
النظره لعقيده الحرب الهجينه التي صادق
عليها
قواعد الحرب تغيرت الوسائل غير العسكريه
يمكن ان تكون اكثر فعاليه من اللجوء الى
القوه ويمكن ان تحقق اهداف الاستراتيجيه
ورغم ان جيرسي موف لم يسلم من الانتقادات
بسبب الانتكاسات الروسيه في ساحه المعركه
والفشل في تحقيق نصر سريع باقل الخسائر
كما كان يتوقع الا ان القياده الروسيه
تراهن الان على خبره قائد عملياتها الجديد
في اداره المرحله القادمه من العمليات
العسكريه انطلاقا من اقليم جمباز كان نقطه
ارتكاز لتغيير موازين القوى